the prize ingredient in a restaurant
kitchen these days the people Britain
has a shortage of workers and it's hit
Hospitality hard
the Oakman group employs 1600 people in
40 venues but recruiting and retaining
them comes at a price
since brexit it's got a lot harder again
there have been shortages across my
industry our Energy bill has got up by
about 70 our labor cost by 20 odd
percent food and drink by you know food
in particular probably 20 plus drink a
bit lower but we've only been able to
achieve about an eight percent increase
in in our prices so profits are being
squeezed and we need a way out of it
with more than a million vacancies
unfilled across the country competition
for staff is forcing up pay in the three
months to April wages were 7.2 percent
higher than a year ago the fastest
increase outside the pandemic but that's
still less than CPI inflation running at
8.7 percent which means real wages the
spending power of the pound in your
pocket actually fell 2.3 percent there
are fewer people working since covid too
some through early retirement but record
numbers through long-term sickness
further squeezing the market Rising
wages is good news for workers these
figures include an increase in the
minimum wage but they can indicate
trouble for the economy because they
suggest that inflation is becoming
ingrained and that makes it more likely
the bank of England will again increase
interest rates next week and that will
raise the cost of borrowing for everyone
financial markets now think an increase
is inevitable right this morning's
numbers Illustrated we've got a very
tight labor market in this country we've
had a fall in the supply of labor
um uh which is showing signs of recovery
but it's very slowly frankly we still
think the rate of inflection is going to
come down but it's taking a lot longer
than we expected the tight labor market
may be fueling inflation and restricting
growth and the price of some government
borrowing has exceeded even the chaos of
Lids trusses mini budget not a recipe
for short-term success Sky News in
Woburn